CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer on
the Android Team at Google.
I do a bunch of work on
animations, and I've done some
DevBytes in the past on
ListView animations.
And I got a request to show how
you might animate adding
and removing items from
the ListView.
So recently, I did a talk with
Romain Guy on animations at
Google I/O. You might want to
check that out since it has
some of the content and related
content as well.
And one of the demos that I
showed was removing items from
the ListView, exactly
what people wanted.
I've tuned the code a little bit
to make it a little more
general purpose, and we're going
to show a bit more about
how it actually works today.
So the idea with ListView
removals is that you're
deleting an item there.
Maybe you want to
swipe it out.
In the demo that I have, you
swipe these items out, and
then the swipe itself is
animated and after the item is
removed from the ListView, the
ListView collapses the gap
around that item and views move
in from the top or the
bottom, wherever they need to.
And all of this is seamless
to the user.
It's kind of the effect and the
feel that you want with
the ListView, but it may
not be particularly
obvious how to do so.
So let's see how this actually
works today.
Now, one important point that
I should point out, if you
look closely at the code in the
Google I/O version of this
demo, you'll see that I was
using a property called
Transient State, which was
added in Jelly Bean.
I've actually removed that.
It's used implicitly under the
hood when you use the View
Property Animator, but I'm not
using it explicitly in the
demo code anymore, because I
actually found a more general
purpose way of doing this
animation so it's a little
more applicable to different
releases as well.
So let's see how it works.
So if we take a look at the
code, one important point--
and this is right at the heart
of why I don't need Transient
State anymore-- is that I'm
using a Stable Array Adapter.
This is a subclass of Array
Adapter that I created to
return True for Has
Stable IDs.
This is a key element because
I'm no longer animating the
views directly, getting
information directly from the
views and then making sure that
those views all stay on
the screen at the same time.
That's dependent upon the
Jelly Bean capability of
Transient State.
Instead, I am dependent upon the
underlying Array Adapter
to have Stable IDs so that I
can count on those items
actually being the same
as changes in the
Array Adapter happen.
So I do that by returning True
there, and when I get Item ID,
I actually get unique IDs
as I process the array.
And then the only other custom
thing that happens in this
Array Adapter is I set an On
Touch Listener because every
item in the view, as it's
created, I want it to know
where to go for its touch events
because I'm going to
customize that with some swiping
behavior, which we'll
see very soon.
So if we go back to our Activity
Class, here's that
Touch Listener that we were
just talking about.
So the idea here is this.
I want to note when the user
clicks down, and I want to
note when they swipe
left to right.
Because I want to, first, detect
when it's gone far
enough that we're actually
in a swiping motion.
So I'm going to start animating
that as they move
their finger.
So then I want to position the
view, and I want to also set
the alpha of the view to make it
disappear more, the closer
to the edge of the screen
that it gets.
And then when they actually let
go of that item, I want to
determine whether to snap the
item back or to animate it all
the way off.
I should point out that in the
widgets that we actually ship,
we use Velocity Tracking, which
is a better way to do
this in general.
I'm using a simple heuristic
of how far have you moved
instead, which works for the
purposes of the demo.
I think a more full version of
this effect would actually use
Velocity Tracking instead so
that as you lifted off your
finger as you're swiping to the
right, then the item would
actually animate at the same
speed that it was just moving,
which is a nicer effect.
Nevertheless, a simple approach
here, and also simple
to change using Velocity
instead.
So when the user presses down,
if there's another item
pressing, I'm not handling
multi-touch clicks here.
We're just making a simple demo
here so we return False.
We're not going to handle
this event.
Otherwise, we set the value to
say, OK, we're now tracking
things, and we're going to note
the initial location that
they pressed down in so that
we know how far to move the
item in initial move events.
When there is a subsequent move
event here, we get the
current location of that, and
then we know how far the user
has moved the item in general,
and then we also know whether
to detect for swipe slop, which
is basically how far
have they moved?
Have they moved past the point
where yes, we think it's not
just an error, but we should
actually start
swiping this thing out.
So you see a little jump at
the beginning as we detect
that it's not just noise but
they're actually moving it far
enough for us to start
swiping it away.
We tell the ListView to disallow
intercept touch
events, because I don't want
the ListView doing its own
thing with scrolling up and down
at the same time as I'm
trying to swipe items
back and forth.
So when you call this method and
set it to True, then until
the final Up Event from the
Touch Event Processor, then
the items have full
control over here.
The ListView will not
get in your way.
And then we tell the Background
Container to show
the background.
We'll get into this a
little bit later.
This is the detail about what
exactly are we going to show
behind the item as
it's swiped away?
So if we're actually swiping
this thing, then we're going
to set the translation x.
So we're going to move this item
back and forth according
to how far the user's finger has
moved, and we're going to
set the alpha.
We basically want it to be the
inverse of how far away it is
from wherever they started.
So the closer they get to the
edge of the screen one way or
the other, the more translucent
it's going to be,
the idea being that it's going
to fade out all the way by the
time it gets off the screen.
And then finally, when the user
lifts up, if they were
swiping this thing, then we
can find out how far they
swiped it, whether they're going
off the screen to the
left, off the screen to the
right, and then we can set the
duration based on that.
We're going to set the duration
based on how far they
have left to go to the edge of
the screen, whether it's
popping back into place or
actually popping all the way
off the screen.
We're going to set enabled
False on the ListView.
This prevents the user from
doing something silly like
actually scrolling and flinging
the ListView at the
same time as we're animating
all the views into place.
Makes things look a little bit
more consistent and reasonable
on the screen.
And then we're going to set
that enabled to True when
we're actually all done
with the animation.
There's two animations that
are going to kick in here.
The first is that we're going
to animate the Swipe Out or
the Swipe Back.
And if it was a Swipe Out,
then we're going to run a
following animation, which is
going to animate the closure
of the gap that that item
created when it was removed
from the list.
So we're going to set the
duration according to that
duration that we calculated
before.
We're going to animate alpha.
This is using a View Property
Animator, which was an API
that came in in 3.1,
Honeycomb 3.1.
And we're also going to animate
translation x to its
end value, either back all the
way on the screen or all the
way off the screen.
And then we're going
to run End Action.
Now this is an API that came in
in Jelly Bean, so if you're
writing for Jelly Bean and
later, that's fine.
If you're writing for run times
that are earlier than
Jelly Bean, you don't have to
use an End Action here.
Instead, you can set up a
listener on the View Property
Animator, and it's just a little
bit more code, but it's
effectively the same thing.
When the end of the animation
happens, we're
going to run this code.
So the swipe has happened.
Now we actually want to animate
the removal, animate
removing the gap in
the ListView.
So if we're actually removing
the item if it was swiped off,
then we're going to animate
removal here.
Otherwise, we're all done, and
we're just going to restore
the values that we need.
So animate removal
is down here.
Now, this is the different
approach from the one that we
took at Google I/O. The talk
in Google I/O talked about
let's track where the views
are here and let's set
Transient State on all those
views to make sure that they
don't get recycled when
the layout occurs.
We don't care about that anymore
because we're using
Item IDs instead.
So what's happening
is the following.
For all children that are
currently in the ListView--
and this is before
layout runs.
So there's no data
set change yet.
The list is just the way that
it was at the time that the
user was swiping it-- we're
going to track where these
things are.
So we want to know where the
views are, but we're going to
store that information about
position in a hash map that's
keyed off of the Item ID instead
of the view itself.
So for every view, we're going
to say, where are you now?
We're going to get the top
value, child.getTop.
We're going to find out where
it is in its container, and
we're going to store that
information with the key of
the Item ID that's associated
with that view before Layout
runs and Recycle happens and
everything gets all confused
in the ListView.
But we don't care, because we've
got the information we
need, Item ID associated
with position of
the view at the time.
Then we're actually going to
remove the item, and we're
going to remove it
from the adapter.
That automatically does a
Notify Data Set change.
And then we use a trick that's
common to a lot of my
animation demos, which is we set
an On Pre-Draw Listener.
So what's happened is we've
removed the item.
This is going to force
a Layout to
happen on the ListView.
Views are probably going
to be recycled.
We're going to chuck them
out of the ListView.
We're going to figure out
where items need to go.
Then we're going to
repopulate views.
And who knows what
view is where?
But we don't care, because
we have stable IDs.
We're good to go.
Layout is going to happen, and
then our Pre-Draw Listener is
going to be called.
And this is the important
point.
It's going to be called
before draws happen.
So Layout runs, then it calls
our On Pre-Draw Listener, and
then we can do whatever
we want.
And what we want to do is set
up an animation to animate
views from where they were in
the previous frame into where
we want them to be now that
Layout has run and the
ListView has finalized
all the content for
these views that changed.
So the On Pre-Draw Callback
gets called here.
We remove the Listener, because
we don't care about it
after this one frame, then we
come in here and walk through
all current children
of the ListView.
So this is everything after
Layout ran, everything got
recycled, shuffled around.
For every one of those, we're
going to say, OK,
where are you now?
Give me your current
top position.
And if the position
of that same ID--
so I'm also tracking the current
ID of this view, and I
know what the ID used to
be for that content
before Layout ran.
And if we have a non-null value
for Start Top, that
means that this view used to
be somewhere else in the
container, and we're going to
run an animation to animate
that change in values.
So if the top position before
Layout for this content is
different than the top position
for that item after
Layout, then we want to
run the animation.
So we're going to set an initial
translation y value to
basically run it back to
wherever it started from, and
then we're going to animate
to translation y of 0.
So we're basically just going
to animate it into place.
If this is the first time it's
running, then we want to, with
the first animation, go ahead
and restore some values when
we're done, kind of a tedious
detail there.
If there is no starting position
for that particular
content item, then that means
that this view is just moving
onto the screen, either from
the bottom or the top.
So we calculate an initial
position to start from, and
there's a little bit of
repeated code there.
Don't worry about that.
And then we come in here and
we, again, set the initial
translation y value to that
delta, and we animate it.
The animation code is exactly
what we saw before.
The only difference is
calculating the initial
position for an item that was
previously off the screen,
didn't exist in the ListView
container before.
And then when we're all done, we
clear the top map, which is
where we were storing these
values of Item IDs associated
with the top positions.
That's all the animation
code here.
The only other thing that's
interesting here is the
Background Container.
So there's kind of a graphics
optimization here where, if we
are constantly drawing a
background behind a ListView
where all of the items are
opaque, then that means we're
basically getting overdraw.
We're drawing an entire
background, and then we're
drawing all the items on top of
that background, which is
kind of a wasted effort.
If you really care about
animation, if you really care
about performance and you notice
that you're getting
bottlenecked in some situations,
then one way you
could work around this is to set
a null background on that
container so that we're
not going to draw
anything behind it.
Well, that's a problem if you're
swiping out and you see
into the nothingness that's
behind the ListView.
So what we do is when we start
doing the swipe, we tell the
Background Container to
show the background.
That sets up some initial values
here so that we know
where to draw this
item background.
And then we override on Draw and
say, OK, if we're drawing
this thing, then we'll go ahead
and translate to the
open area, and we'll draw
our shadowed background.
And our shadowed background
is seen here.
This is called from the
constructors, and we simply
load in this resource.
This is a nine patch
that I defined.
It's very simple.
It's basically shadow on top,
shadow on bottom, and then an
area in the middle that
gets stretched.
And the net effect, which you
can see in the demo, is that
we have a little bit of shadow
on top and a little bit of
shadow on bottom, and then this
grey area in the middle,
so it makes it look like all of
the items in the ListView
are popped out from this virtual
background that we
have there.
Another item to mention is
sometimes when you're
animating ListViews, if you have
dividers in the ListView
and you're playing with things
like we are here, like
animating the translation
properties, you may notice the
dividers aren't necessarily
getting drawn correctly.
So I disabled dividers.
So if you take a look at the
layout for application, we
have ListView divider of null
and a divider height of zero.
So the ListView itself is not
drawing dividers, and instead,
I've defined the TextView to
actually use a divider.
So it's using a background,
which I defined, which is
basically all opaque white with
an opaque line at the
bottom of it, and that gives
me my own divider that gets
animated along with these items
as they're moving around
the ListView.
So again, this is ListView
removal animations.
It's the ability to animate
all the changes.
You could do a very similar
thing with adding.
I just only took care of the
one direction today.
But it's doing it in a way that
is usable on all property
animation APIs all the way back
to when View Property
Animator came in,
which was 3.1.
In fact, you could use Object
Animator for everything and
take it all the way
back to 3.0.
And if you want a little teaser,
in a future demo,
we'll see how we can use a very
similar technique and
actually run this thing on
Gingerbread as well.
So check out the talk at Google
I/O that we did on
animation called "A Moving
Experience," and download the
code and play with
it, and make your
ListViews more dynamic.
Thanks.